and joining us now is the 70th Secretary
of State Fox News contributor Mike
Pompeo is with us Mr secretary um the
way I see it is prime minister Netanyahu
has no option here no choice here this
is the worst attack ever on on Israeli
soil um this uh the only thing that I
might be a little surprised at I mean
the Israelis intelligence is is known as
the go the world's gold standard
something certainly went wrong here I'm
not sure what it probably is not the
time to talk about it let's get your
overall view on what we're seeing by the
way we're also seeing that there have
been you know minutes apart we see uh
Israel is firing into Gaza as the show
uh is going on right
now well Sean thanks for having me on um
this is grotesque it is barbaric and it
requires winning and prime minister
Netanyahu gets that and I am just hoping
that this Administration doesn't slow
him down these are going to be long
weeks there going to be some pictures
that come out of Gaza that are going to
be trag IC but make no mistake about it
prime minister nanyu has the duty to
defend his own people in the same way
that the United States has that has that
Duty we now have Americans held hostage
and Hamas puppet of Iran is threatening
to kill them they've already killed 11
Americans they're threatening to kill
Americans live on video and broadcast
the audio as well and President Biden
hasn't told the Iranians he hasn't told
the world what America's response to
that will be I remember Sean so well
when the Iranians threatened to kill
Americans on our watch when they were
launching artillery into the embassy
American Embassy in Baghdad Iraq we made
clear we would hold not the Knuckleheads
on the ground in Iraq but we would hold
the Iranian regime responsible when we
did that we didn't create World War III
as they said we might when we stay got
out of the jcpoa when we move the
embassy they said we'd create World War
III no what has created War here is
American appeasement American weakness
and if we don't stand with Israel if we
don't give them the tools that they need
to prosecute this to the end until Hamas
is wiped out in the Iranian regime
understands that the Israelis mean
business and they have American Support
then we will risk even more American
lives Mr secretary let me go over I
don't I maybe you can explain this to me
the first Iranian deal was Barack Obama
and Joe Biden and for the life of me I
never quite understood that deal that
would allow them to continue their
nuclear program and and Ratchet it up as
a matter of fact every year after every
year uh they didn't have any as part of
that deal no us inspectors billions of
dollars going to Iranian mullers they
didn't have anywhere any place any time
inspections uh I don't trust the the
mullers of Iran as far as I can throw
them uh okay Donald Trump becomes
president that policy is is stopped
thankfully and here we are back with the
$6 billion uh in Ransom payments for
five Americans now they can argue all
they want that so far not a penny has of
that 6 billion has gone to Iran but the
money has already been moved mov uh into
cutter where we know it's going to end
up in the Iranians hands and whether
they say it's for humanitarian purposes
or not because the president of Iran has
already said uh you're not going to tell
us how to spend the money um they then
that freeze up money that they would
otherwise be spending on their own
infrastructure humanitarian Aid etc for
more terrorist attacks they are the
number one state sponsor of Terror tell
me where this mindset comes from that
you are going to do business and pay
Ransom to terrorists I have a hard time
understanding
it Sean it's completely unexplainable it
is completely illogical it can it can
only be that it's part of the blame
America First Mantra that we're sort of
the problem in the world you saw this on
Harvard's campus today uh just so
indecent so so grotesque to see
Americans supporting Hamas that's
carting kids into the Gaza Strip to kill
them on live TV uh the the fact that the
$6 billion hasn't been spent yet well
great make clear it's it's not going to
be pull it back and Sean you know this
too uh we had the strictest sanctions
ever imposed on the Iranian regime it
worked we put them in the box we
isolated them it built out the Abraham
Accords and peace throughout the Middle
East at least 20 maybe $30 billion
dollar of Iranian wealth as a direct
result of the Biden Administration just
refusing to enforce the sanctions
they're required to enforce no they it
was Iran that fueled this it is Iran
that is the problem Hamas executed a
mission that was funded trained and
directed by the Iranian I'm confident we
will find that and I'm I'm worried I'm
worried because they're going to do the
same thing in the north they the
Iranians are prepared to the to fight to
the last Hezbollah life or the last
Hamas life it is going to have to be
Iran that gets cost imposed on it or
this will continue what how would you
impose those costs because I agree with
you ultimately all the proxy wars that
have that have been fought in the region
they all seem to have their origins of
monies and support coming from Iran we
now even have direct reports that the
Iranian revolutionary guard gave the
okay offered the weapons gave the
financial support so what price does uh
Iran pay in all of this and how do they
pay
it so the first step is to make sure
Israel secures its own space it's got to
go take down Hamas every every last
person who's connected this got to be
wiped off second the United States
should demand that not only United
States but every other uh country stop
providing any money to Iran they're
still funding the Palestinians in Judea
and Samaria they're still underwriting
all kinds of programs that go to these
terrorists we've got to stop all of that
funding it could be done tomorrow
President Biden just has to say so and
then we need to make sure that we deny
Iranians the chance to come to school in
the United States the list is long we
have done it Sean we we know precisely
how to execute this we don't have to
imagine how you build out peace and
stability in the Middle East because we
had done it for four years the bid
Administration just came in ripped it up
turned it upside down and the deaths
that happened today or the
responsibility of Hamas they were caused
by Iran but the conditions were set by
by American weakness in Afghanistan by
allowing Vladimir Putin to think that a
small Invasion might be okay and then
ultimately not to convince the Iranians
that we would have Israel's back when
your first instinct when your first
instinct is to say can't we all just get
along and the Israelis need to stand
down and then the Secretary of State
sends out a tweet that also had to be
taken down because he demanded a
ceasefire those are the things the
Iranians observe they know that America
is not serious and I pray that President
Biden understands what is at risk it is
Israel and America's place in the world
and we have to get this right well
you're talking about specifically you
know we urge all sides to refrain from
violence and retaliatory uh attacks you
know if you break it down you know and
look at the population of Israel versus
the population of the United States this
attack would be the equivalent of in one
day killing over 35,000 Americans would
that be their position to stand down and
not not have a retaliatory uh strike
against the people that would killed
35,000
Americans that's my first question and
then secondly what part is Saudi Arabia
playing here because they seem to
condemn Israel in this and I thought
that Israel and the Saudis were on the
verge of making a deal
together so two thoughts one no we
should definitely not be telling Israel
no one should be telling Israel how to
conduct its foreign policy prime
minister netan should have a free hand
to do what he needs to do I saw a
statement from the from the General
Secretary of the United Nations today
that just was sickening talking about
how we need to make sure that everyone
obeys international law goodness when
when you're raping women and dragging
them back to go that's not international
law second you know with the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia um I hope that what will
happen is that they will push forward is
that the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia will
see the fact that Iran is a problem not
only for Israel but for the amadis the
kuwaitis and for them as well they will
understand that the risk of this Terror
regime from the Islamic Republic of Iran
is a risk to them as well and this
effort to bring them in to the abrahamic
courts to create peace and to recognize
Israel will push forward I'm counting on
that happening I hope that it will it
would make perfect sense for everyone in
the region to see that happen let me ask
you Mr secretary Hamas terrorists uh we
have evidence and and video footage uh
beheading Israeli soldiers we have Hamas
executing that teenage girl uh hostage
in front of her parents and then you
have people like congresswoman TB
blasting Israel in the wake of this um
how do you explain that wing of the
democratic party that seems to be
getting louder and louder and more more
dominant every single
day it's unexplainable Sean I have no
capacity to comprehend how you could
watch what has taken place there and
have any idea that the right answer to
that is to blame the victims of this
tragedy we we we we see reminiscences of
what happened in the Holocaust right we
see women and children being dragged off
to their death and for a congressman not
to call that out to say no that's the
problem and somehow say that those
victims are to blame for what's happened
is fundamentally indecent and I hope the
good people that she represents vote her
out immediately we we H we have to make
sure that we all understand that what is
happening here is going to go on for a
while this is going to be of duration it
is going to require a lot of strength
and tarity and it is going to demand the
American people join together to protect
the basic human dignity that America has
stood for for 250 plus years you know Mr
secretary I shudder to think of a day
when the Iranian mullers with their
radicalism married to nuclear weapons
and they seem to be desperately trying
to get them uh they have now formed what
I call a new axis of Evil with with
China and with Russia and and we can see
North Korea becoming a part of it um and
I shudder to really ask this question
question and I think it's the hardest
question does the world have a very
limited window here to prevent Iran from
acquiring nuclear weapons and does that
does do those strikes need to happen
sooner than
later Sean the I think the window is
closing we absolutely have to get after
it we saw this in the Trump
Administration and we began this process
with actions that we took including
striking against their leader kasum
sulamani General suani taking seriously
the need to push back against Iranian
leadership I I do worry about these
nuclear weapons remember this
Administration went back to a policy
that gave them money and allowed them to
continue to enrich uranium we have to
reverse that they should go right back
into our model of punishing Iran uh
imposing restrictions on Iran and
denying them the capacity to continue to
develop their nuclear weapons program we
have the ability to do that and if we
can't stop them through those
restrictions then we've got to do the
right thing and make sure this regime
never gets even remotely close to
weaponizing those nucle they already
have aren't they buried deep within the
ground all out throughout the territory
of of
Iran Sean they are but make no mistake
about it if America is serious and
Israel is serious and the threat is
sufficient I am very confident then we
can make sure that a weapons program is
stopped inside of Iran it will take a
seriousness that I have not seen a
resolve I have not seen from the Biden
administration too much Jimmy Carter not
enough Ronald Reagan if we get it right
I'm confident that we can prevent that
from happening it would have to be BB
acting alone cuz he'll get no help or
support at all from Joe Biden I don't
think they're capable of it but uh we
need the adults back in charge that's
for sure SEC former Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo thank you sir hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else